hi I'm Brady I make the numberphile
videos and there's just a few quick
messages I wanted to share firstly we
had bit of a glitch this week and it
seems our last video didn't go to most
of our subscribers and it's a really
cool one it's a collaboration with via
heart all about tetrahedral dice if you
don't know what I'm talking about I
haven't seen it you may not have got it
and I'll put a link under the video and
on the screen next I just want to say
something about our notorious bits of
brown paper you see them all the time in
our videos and this is a whole bunch
from previous films some people love
them and some people hate them I've
written a blog about why I use it so I'm
not going to cover it again now but I
just wanted you to know let me grab
something here hang on this particular
piece it's the Nepalese flag from our
video about the most mathematical flag
in the world well that's actually up for
auction at the moment on eBay we're
raising money for charity if you're
interested and would like to own this
piece of numberphile history why don't
you put in a bid and if it proves
popular maybe some of those other ones
can go to charity as well next I just
wanted to mention a video that was sent
in by a viewer when we were doing all
our Rubik's Cube films it's one that I
really meant to show everyone at the
time but didn't really get the chance so
I just want to highlight it now
basically it's from a guy called either
shy or che I'm not sure how to pronounce
his name but he's got a whole bunch of
Rubik's cubes of different style and he
managed to make them say numberphile and
then he solved every single one of them
and I reckon that's pretty amazing and
worth a special mention while we're
having this chat I thought this might be
a good opportunity to hear what you want
us to be making films about so why not
use this video in the comment section
below to give us some suggestions and
tell us more about what you'd like to
see lastly I don't normally do these
sort of messages in videos but I do that
people know what's going on via Twitter
and Facebook you can follow us on there
there's always a little bit extra
pictures chances to get involved so sign
up for those if you're that kind of
social media person a reminder again if
you didn't see the via heart video links
are below and under the video I'm gonna
put loads of links to all my other
channels because some of you don't
realize
when I'm not obsessing about numbers
I've got a whole bunch of other videos
about chemistry and astronomy and
physics you can check them out too
thanks for watching I'm actually flying
off to San Francisco now but I'll be
back next week putting up new
numberphile videos